it's a great
great thing i wanted it to be called the
donald j trump accord but i didn't think
the press would understand that sorry
i didn't do that obviously a few words
thank you mr president uh it's really
been the honor of my life to work in
your administration
i think this re-reaffirms
your commitment to israel to disability
in the region
uh it's just a historic accomplishment
and it's it's peace
peace is a beautiful thing and it's
something that everybody in the country
should celebrate i hope
um i'm just so honored to uh to be here
sir well you've done a great job and
jared has done a fantastic job people
don't uh really understand the things
that he's able to do
he's done a fantastic job on this and
you and your team
nobody else could have done it i don't
think anybody else could have done it
jared say a few words
thank you mr president and i would like
to say that
i want to thank the president for his
leadership on this historic peace effort
the president like with all things urged
us to take an untraditional approach
you can't solve problems that have gone
unsolved by doing it the same way that
people before you have tried and failed
the president takes untraditional
approaches he does things in different
ways
but he uses common sense and he tries to
unite people by
focusing on common interests as opposed
to allowing them to focus on their
common grievances
and what happened was here is we were
able to achieve results that others were
not able to achieve
and this will advance the region and
this will advance the whole world i
would like to say to the people of the
region
muslims jews christians that this does
give hope
that the problems of the past do not
condemn you to
a future with conflict there is a lot of
hope and a lot of potential
and this will benefit you and this will
also benefit people here in america
because in america we used to have a big
dependency on the middle east for
gas and for oil thanks to your
leadership america is now
energy independent we no longer have
that but a lot of american soldiers
have fought for securing our allies in
that region
and making more peace there lessons are
neat as a country to have as many
soldiers in that region and lessens our
need to have as many conflicts in that
region and
obviously radical extremism which we see
as a cancer that has infected
so many areas in the world a lot of the
extremists
have used these conflicts to uh to to
recruit people and to
say that the mosque is under attack and
that muslims don't have access to the
mosque
and now this will enable people to take
flights from dubai and abu dhabi
directly to tel aviv
muslims will be welcomed in israel and
this will create
a better interfaith exchange so this is
a tremendous
step forward for peace in the world for
uh for america
for uh for israel for abu dhabi and uh
all would not have been possible without
your leadership so i just want to thank
you
much thank you what a great job and what
jared said is so that we don't have to
be there
anymore we don't need oil we don't need
anything
there except friendship we have some
great friends
these are two countries that have been
great friends and we've been great
friends to them
but we no longer have to be there it
started off
but we had to be there but as of a few
years ago we don't have to be there we
don't have to be patrolling
the straits uh we're doing things that
uh
other countries wouldn't do but we put
ourselves over the last few years in a
position where we no longer have to be
in
areas that at one point were vital
and that's a big statement but we are
there for our friends and we always will
be there for our friends
robert would you say a few words mr
president thank you uh the point i want
to make mr president you inherited the
middle east that was a mess when you
came to office
and this is one more historic step uh in
bringing peace to the middle east
first of all there was a caliphate that
was raging in isis caliphate
and that physical caliphate was
destroyed and brought justice to
al-baghdadi
uh you reassured our friends in israel
who who had suffered
uh at the end of the last administration
uh with the u.n resolution you moved the
capital to
jerusalem you recognize the golan
heights
in the broader region you had a very
difficult situation in afghanistan where
we were
soldiers or american soldiers were
coming home injured wounded
sadly in some cases dead you brought
you've got a peace agreement now with
the taliban and we're gonna have
less than half the number of troops in
afghanistan that were there when you
started
your term of office and now you've
brought about this historic peace deal
between the uae
and israel this is the first time in 20
25 years
that israel and the arab country have
normalized diplomatic relations and
entered into a peace deal
and are the two most capable countries
in the middle east too very capable very
skilled very innovative allies
of the united states so it's great for
israel it's great for the uae but it's
also great for the american the american
people so
you came in you came into office with a
region that was that was really a flame
and you brought peace to that region and
there's more to come and uh and so it's
an honor to be part of your team mr
president
to serve under your leadership we do
have a lot more to come
in the middle east a lot of very
positive things are happening and
you'll be seeing that taking place but
we can get a leader like uae
to head the band and get along with
israel that's a big
that's a very big step would you please
say a few words you've done such a
fantastic job
thank you mr president uh the trump
administration made history today
it's been an honor to be a part of this
team that jared has led
uh peace between the arabs and the
israelis is iran's worst nightmare
and no one has done more to intensify
the conflict
between arabs and israelis than iran and
what we see today is a new middle east
the trend lines are very different today
and we see
uh the future is very much in the gulf
and with israel
and the past is with the iranian regime
it uh clings to power on the basis of
brute force that is lost
is facing a crisis of legitimacy and
credibility with its own people
and the president's maximum pressure
campaign has achieved historic results
thank you great job would you like to
say
something yes sir uh as a as a soldier
who's been in every war since desert
storm
it is an honor and a privilege for your
leadership sheikh
sheikh mohammed bin zayed and prime
minister netanyahu
uh to get to peace so uh your vision
and uh and those leaders vision uh on
what we can do in the future
is just incredible so i would thank you
as a soldier thank you very much
appreciate it would anybody like to say
a few words anybody here
because you were saying plenty of words
during that negotiation
they got very quiet in front of the
media that happens that happens on
occasion
mr president it's a historic moment uh
thank you for being
letting us all be part of this it is
really extraordinary
nothing is more important than peace
this is
an unbelievable moment and i would just
echo what brian hook said
your maximum pressure campaign under
your leadership we've had the strongest
sanctions on iran
and your commitment to make sure that
iran will never have a nuclear weapon
is part of the most important legacy for
peace in the middle east
so which is easier dealing with the
democrats are dealing with
the middle east well a lot of people
never thought you'd get a
this type of deal so i'll i'll be uh
hopeful that we can deal with the
democrats
the middle east is more reasonable
uh i'd like to say a couple of words
you've been so instrumental please
sir it's a privilege to serve in your
administration uh this is a remarkable
achievement that'll stand the test of
time
uh and we look forward to the prosperity
and the peace this brings the middle
east and the ways we'll be able to
leverage that for the united states
national interest so it's a privilege
thank you thank you very much and i
would just echo what rob said it's
thank you for the opportunity to be part
and especially i want to thank avi
the opportunity to serve in his
negotiating team to do something so
historic
that thank you for this opportunity mr
president this really changes the world
thank you very much thank you thank you
all very much
[Applause]
it was a tremendous relationship has
been built up over the last
i would say year before that was very
tense
as everything in the middle east is it's
very tense it's a very
tense place but it's becoming less dense
and i have great relationships with all
of the leaders
and some of some are enemies against
each other
and i get along with both that's i guess
the big thing people don't understand
that about me i actually
i've gotten along remember when i was
elected they said the war will start
with somebody
within days and i've kept this out of
war you look at north korea everybody
said including president obama that's
the biggest problem
everybody said you'd be in war well
we're not at war
no it would have been a war if i wasn't
elected it was somebody
else now we're uh we're doing very well
in the middle east and i'll tell you
what it's been
an incredible thing but no it was tense
but the relationship has become a very
good one with
between uae and israel and also with
other countries
many other countries and i think you'll
be seeing some
very exciting things including
ultimately with the palestinians i think
that's going to be happening at some
point
because it makes a lot of sense for them
to let it happen
on palestinian land by israel well we're
talking to
israel about that right now
well you really know your stuff don't
you but we're not going to talk to you
about that we're going to work something
out and then we'll talk after it's
completed but it'll be a
very satisfactory why now did they come
to an agreement
uh we've been working on this for a long
time
it's been a labor of love for a lot of
the people in this room
and a lot of them love israel and a lot
of them love the middle east and they
love the countries that we're talking
about
like uae as an example standing right
here
and it's been a labor of love they know
it has to happen
and i don't want to be speaking too much
about it but if you look what's happened
since
i broke up that ridiculous iran nuclear
deal
money isn't going to some horrible
horrible groups and you haven't seen the
kind of terrorism that you saw before
now i don't like saying it
because all of a sudden they'll say
we've got to do something but you know
what
they're not getting money because iran
isn't giving money and i
appreciate that but iran is going
through very difficult times and i
appreciate that
and i'll say this and i can say it very
publicly that if i win the election
i will have a deal made with iran within
30 days
they'll make a very fast deal they're
dying to make a deal but they'd much
rather negotiate with sleepy joe biden
then with
us but we'll uh we'll be having a
deal made very very quickly uh but you
know
rightfully they're waiting till after
the election because they would
there's nothing china iran russia
all of them would like to see more than
have trump be defeated where they could
deal with jill biden
because that would be like a dream and
this was something that was very
exciting we thought this would be the
first country he's a great leader
muhammad's a great leader
and we're very happy that he was the
first country i would say and
you're going to see many other things
happening in the middle east over a
fairly short period of time
but this is the first time in more than
25 years and
and uae is big stuff uae is very
powerful
very strong as one of the strongest
militaries
it's big stuff do you know what the
delegations are going to meet
specifically
very soon i guess they'll be setting up
the meetings do you have any time
i think the next several weeks mr
president and then we expect that there
will be a uh
a meeting here at the white house with
the uh there'll be an official signing
at the white house over the next
few weeks okay and other than that we'll
meet you at 5 30 or so we'll talk
and we'll actually take one of your
questions okay
[Applause]
now